[Music]
what's up guys so to become an Avenger
are there like trials or an interview do
me a favor can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man just stay close
to the ground
you're the spider-man from you two
can you summon an army of spiders Oh Ned
no do you know him - stole a shield can
I try the suit on but uh the rich and
the powerful like Stark they don't care
about us
the world's changing boys time we change
too
these weapons are crazy dangerous
missing Peter forget the flying monster
guy there are people who handle this
sort of thing illegal weapons Barry was
a 230 you missed it
[Music]
what if somebody had died I was just
trying to be like you I wanted to be
better I'm gonna need the suit back but
I'm nothing without this suit if you're
nothing without this suit then you
shouldn't have it I screwed up you need
to stop carrying the weight of the world
on your shoulders I want you to
understand I'll do anything to protect
my family I know you know what I'm
talking about
so don't mess with me
because I'll kill you and everybody you
love
[Music]
is still out there I've just got to do
this on my own
just don't do anything stupid
all right yeah
[Music]
you